solving equations okay now what
continuous on you've already looked some
so for instance as an example someone's
we look at things like this x equals so
what would we do in this case to solve
this equation okay very good so you can
think about this in one of two ways okay
and you can have some metaphors in your
head so number one you could say this
five moves over to the other side but in
doing so it becomes the opposite of what
was before so that's why it's a minus bi
alternatively you could say what I'm
doing really is to both sides of the
equation like a like a set of scale
right I'm subtracting five from here
which means I subtract five from there
that's a really helpful metaphor okay to
see that because these two sides are
equal do something to one side
Venna do it to you okay and of course
they let me take away five is great and
you've solved it okay now by the way
just as a side note what does it mean
that we have solved this equation that
we have a solution what's the point of
that what x is right we found the value
of that pretty rule I can take this six
and I can pop it back in my original and
it will work okay what makes a solution
a solution is that it satisfies the
original
line that we got given right the
original equation that's what solutions
do okay now when you see we're going to
go into a few different kinds of
problems today the metaphor I have in my
head on top of life balancing scales and
I'm gonna be it's actually a chessboard
okay now I don't know how many of you
were nutty enough like me we play chess
in quite a lot of it when you were
younger or even now it's like I still
play chess okay chess the game the aim
of the game is you've got I've only
drawn a small part of it because you
know it's embarrassing enough that up
for me
they're quite bad but you've got your
army the other player has their army
right and the whole goal is just I want
to get the king I want to get the King
okay I want to be able to place my
pieces in such a way that I can you know
kill off the king and we call that
checkmate right now what you're trying
to do in solving equations is just the
same have a look at this arrangement
right those of you who are actually
Chester know know how this comes about
what's it's called what's he's called
like this particular arrangement is in
the north
it's called Castle II right because what
happens is the key to a guy with that
cross on his head and the rook they kind
of do this weird dance and swap places
and what they create is something that
looks like a castle right he's nice and
secure in there okay the King is really
hard to get to when he's protected like
this okay what you want to do if you're
the player trying to attack that is get
the King by himself right you want to
sort of attack these these guys out the
front will lure them away in some way or
attack this guy and take him out of each
other so the king is by himself so the
king is by himself and it's exactly what
we are trying to do when we are solving
an equation that printing room right the
prime know that whatever it is wherever
it is where you start it's surrounded by
other stuff at the moment it doesn't
have that much here but we're going to
add more things on as you'll see and our
goal in solving is just to get the king
by himself that's all you want okay
that's a bit of a game literally it's
like how can I rearrange things how can
I engineer this situation to get him on
his own and then I've solved it okay so
if you haven't already please open up to
page 393 or in your text books I
understand you got a few of those
questions done questions 1 2 & 3 I think
the first column so this is an example
it was a little relief well it's not
quite the first question okay you can
see that there's a plus 5 there right so
we got the king by himself by doing
minus 5
okay as a second
if for instance I've got 6x equals let's
do today you've got 6 times X right so
in order to get the king by himself in
order to get X on its iron what am I
gonna do by science
yam okay so I'm going to divide both
sides by 6 and that'll get the King on
his own x of course equals 30 divided by
6 is 5 now you can see questions
floor and following they take the same
ID they're just using different kinds of
operations so for instance let's have a
look at say mmm let's do Part D it looks
like
now the king sometimes wears different
clothes you'll see different pronumerals
they're like X or W but it doesn't
matter you're still playing the same
game and the rules are the same okay so
what should I do to both sides in this
case so you get W by itself there's a
division by two
yeah multiply makes you very good so
I'll do x 2 and x 2 ok so on the
left-hand side my shoes will disappear
and on the right-hand side 29 x 2 you
can do that when your head it almost CT
is in it but it's 1 a.m. but it's on 1
mod of 2 less than 60 fantastic now all
of these are what we call one-step
equations in fact I think that's leaving
the title of the exercise right because
there's only one step one step one step
one step required to get the king by
himself okay but if you stick forward
come over to page 396 okay let's have a
look at this first question let's do 180
so now we're in exercise 1002
okay this is the question right now you
can see there's a few more numbers
flying around it's a bit like there are
more pieces guiding the king okay but we
can play the same game there's a couple
of different things I could do here see
how there's a times two and this 7 okay
now what anyone like to suggest to me
what might be a first step I could do
Adam I think you're head of that first -
ok very good
I'm gonna take away 7 I'm gonna do it
from both sides though both sides so on
the left hand side when I take away 7 I
just get left with I just get left with
to him and when I take my 7 from the
right hand side I'm gonna get 12 so
let's do there's my first step one step
but now I have to do my second step I've
got more three times so now I divide by
two right which gives me ms6 very good
ok so that's one way of doing it that
was fine we subtracted 7 first then we
divided by 2 okay but it's not the only
way you can do it have a look I could
have decided well I want to get rid of
the two first right so if I divide both
sides by 2 find you at first what will
happen the 2a will turn into an M what
does 7 turn into when you divide it by 2
3 and a half very good
19 when you divide that by 2
mmm it's 9 it's 9 to 1/2 because almost
20 right so therefore this is almost 10
okay and now I've gotten rid of the 2 so
now I just have to get rid of this 3 and
1/2 how do I do it
I'm gonna subtract 3 and 1/2 from both
sides
that leaves me just M on the left and
unsurprisingly 6 just like you thought
before okay now both of these methods
work they both give us the solution they
both satisfy the original equation but
which do you prefer why is the first one
generally preferable yeah
yeah but I don't have to worry about
these fractions right now fractions are
different we have calculated stuff right
but if I can appoint them why not hey
why not so this idea he gave him by
itself this is no pieces okay I'm ghost
using the same rules